first to some breaking news out of libya
where its deputy defence minister says
government troops have taken control of
tahuna
that's the last stronghold of warlord
khalifa haftar in western libya about 65
kilometers
from the capital tripoli on friday the
u.n recognized government announced it
had regained
full control of tripoli hafta's forces
still hold
large swathes of territory in the east
and the south of the country
sami handy is the editor-in-chief of the
online magazine international interest
he's joining us now
from london sami good to have you with
us as always just give us an indication
why tahuna particularly
is so important
half dollars offensive on tripoli had
two key uh
strongholds it was launched from two key
strongholds
the first was always the air base that
was taken not too long ago and the
second was
tarahuna after the fall of lawati
haftar's forces knew that they could not
hold on to
the tripoli offensive uh so they began
to withdraw some of their troops
and taruna or the news from taruna comes
after the gna went to
moscow and after a meeting between
erdogan
and saraj the president of the gna where
it's believed that turkey and russia
are now negotiating a framework of
cooperation so taruna today it's unclear
whether it fell
because of the military attack by the
gna forces
or whether this is part of a negotiated
exchange between the russians and
between
the texts with regards to libya but in
terms of its significance
it means the end complete end of
haftar's
tripoli offensive and the military
solution that hafter offered
to those powers that wanted the military
solution is no longer on the table
and we're back to the status quo as it
was before the beginning of the tripoli
offensive
east and west sami you say that this is
significant in terms of the balance of
power but haftar still controls
significant parts
of libya itself so what happens next are
we likely to see some sort of resurgence
from haftar's forces
i think it it's important not to get
carried away with i know there's a lot
of people very happy with
uh the end of hafta's military solution
and anybody who wants to negotiate a
political solution
should celebrate the fact that after uh
tripoli offensive uh has failed
however as you said it's important to
put it into context this is the end of
hefter's bid to completely win
in the civil war this is what we're
seeing today is a return to the status
quo
the stalemate that we saw for many years
between east and between west
and this prospect of a military campaign
eastwards is very unlikely and the
reason i say this is that
the the biggest dynamic is not
necessarily in the military terms
the biggest dynamic is the changing in
power brokers it's no longer eu it's no
longer european countries
it's no longer uae or egypt or these
countries it's now russia
on the eastern side and turkey on the
western side almost a repeat of syria in
the sense that
these are the countries that are going
to be pushing the parties to decide what
the future of libya
should look like and that's why we're
hearing talks of partition talks of
autonomous regions
talks of a status quo whereby west will
be turkey influence gna
and east will be tubrik influenced
russia
so in other words what we're seeing
today is not a complete
alt alternating of the dynamics of the
war we're seeing a return to the status
quo
that was in 2019 before the start of the
tripoli offensive
and the road ahead to find some sort of
solution to the war
is still very long and if anything even
more complicated now
because of the ferocity of the
international struggle
a resurgent us a very angry france a
confused germany
and italy that is scrambling russia
which is asserting itself
turkey which is now the dominant power
in other words it looks far more
complicated and far more complex than it
looked
three two or three years ago let's talk
about that potential political solution
what role if any can khalifa haftar hope
to have
in that political solution
the it's interesting that the the gna or
members of the gna have actually called
for the mps in tobruk to come and join
them in other words this idea of
trying to merge the two institutions
what is also interesting is that
supporters of the gna and supporters of
the government have absolutely lambasted
the suggestion
with many supporters of gna saying that
tobruk should be held to account
for the crimes that it has done and it
is these attitudes that are very
worrying
the attitude that is does it hasn't
changed from 2011
where we saw revenge attacks reprisals
we saw uh punishment this idea of
compensation that alienated and
polarized libyan society
and created an environment for khalifa
after uh to thrive
it appears that many gna supporters have
not learned the lessons
from 2011. if we want a political
solution the gna now has a golden
opportunity to present a unified front
this idea of a unified libya but it
needs to have the magnanimity
in order to set aside those grievances
and it looks like the gna
will not be able to do that and this is
why a political solution will look more
distant
we have to remember that a political
solution cannot come about
until the narrative on libya changes
until it becomes one in which
all the libyans have grievances all the
libyans suffered all the libyan suffered
under 2011
and it needs a leadership that
recognizes that not a leadership that
believes in its right to rule and not a
leadership that believes that it has the
right to take revenge
on other sections of the libyan
population the g a has a golden
opportunity
to bring about some unified stance to
invite the people of toborok
but i fear that the gna has not learned
the lessons of 2011
and whereas it now has an opportunity to
reach out to the east to reach out to
the libyan people
it seems that gna understandably so are
very caught up in their own grievances
very caught up in in this in this midst
of this victory that they've secured on
the military tied
that they are about to lose a golden
opportunity to help facilitate a
complete altering of the socio-political
dynamics that none of the international
powers could ever hope to bring
good to get your thoughts on this as
always sami handy we appreciate it
thanks very much indeed